Memorial Day wasn't easy for Julie. Her mom's birthday was May 31. And her mom had officially declared that the period between Mother's Day-- which, of course, is in the middle of May-- and her birthday would be known in the family as "gala time." Which meant, basically, it would be the one time during the year where mom would get whatever she wanted. Which would've been fine except what mom often wanted was a road trip into the mountains on curvy roads, which didn't match Julie's personal style when Julie was a kid.
对于朱莉来说，阵亡将士纪念日并不好过。她妈妈的生日是5月31日。她妈妈曾正式宣布，从母亲节（当然是在5月中旬）到她生日之间的这段时间，在家里被称为“庆典时光”。这意味着，基本上，这将是妈妈一年中可以随心所欲的唯一时间。这本来也没什么，但问题是妈妈往往想要去山区走走蜿蜒的道路，这与朱莉小时候的个人风格并不匹配。
I puked everywhere and always. I puked on every road trip from-- I puked any time we were in the car for longer than, like, a half an hour from the age of 4 to the age of 12. I used to be so drugged up on Dramamine, I didn't really ever experience my summer vacations.
我总是到处呕吐，无一例外。从4岁到12岁，每次只要坐车超过半小时，我就会呕吐。我以前常因服用晕车药而昏昏沉沉，以至于我从未真正体验过我的暑假。
Say that again.
再说一遍。
I'd be so drugged up on Dramamine.
我会因为服用晕车药而变得昏昏沉沉。
You would be?
你会吗？
Yeah.
是的。
All the time?
一直都是这样？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That you wouldn't even experience them as vacations?
以至于你甚至无法将它们当作假期来体验？
No, you just sleep. I would just feel glassy-eyed and kind of sweaty. And I remember we went-- it was a whole trip of the Northwest and Canada and coming down the coast. And I didn't see anything. I don't remember anything. I don't remember Glacier. I don't remember Yellowstone. I don't remember Vancouver. I don't remember anything.
不，你只会睡觉。我只会感到眼神呆滞，还有点出汗。我记得我们去过——那是一次游览西北部和加拿大的长途旅行，然后沿着海岸南下。我什么都没看到。我不记得任何事情了。我不记得冰川了。我不记得黄石公园了。我不记得温哥华了。我不记得任何事情。
For three weeks I was on Dramamine one time. Except for one day, and that one day, I threw up. And so my mom put me back on it. She thought I was getting addicted.
有一次我连续三周都在吃晕车药。除了一天，而那一天，我吐了。于是我妈又让我吃上了。她以为我上瘾了。
To Dramamine?
对晕车药上瘾？
Mm hmm. So she took me off.
嗯哼。所以她不让我吃了。
But then she was more scared of the throw up than of the addiction.
但后来她比起成瘾，更害怕我呕吐。
I, like, power threw up all over the car. And my brother had two pairs of shoes right in front of me and I threw up one in each shoe. So he had to wear a pair of dress shoes and a pair of Nike's. And I threw up in my brother's baseball card collection that was also on the floor in front of me. Different brother.
我当时简直是把全身的力气都用来呕吐，弄得车里到处都是。我弟弟当时就在我面前放了两双鞋，我每只鞋里都吐了一些。所以他不得不穿着一只正装鞋和一只耐克鞋。我还吐在了他放在我脚下的棒球卡收藏里。是另一个弟弟。
Well, this is the week of Memorial Day. And the thing about Memorial Day and the beginning of summer is that every person, every family has its Achilles' heel when summer finally arrives. If it's not the one person who gets sick in the car, it's the person who hates the sun; or the one who can't stand the beach; or the person who loves the beach-- loves it so hard, so fiercely so thoroughly that no one else in the family can understand it.
嗯，这就是阵亡将士纪念日的那一周。关于阵亡将士纪念日和夏季的开始，每个人的每个家庭在夏天真正到来时都有自己的“阿喀琉斯之踵”。如果不是那个在车里晕车的人，那就是讨厌阳光的人；或者是忍受不了海滩的人；或者是那个热爱海滩的人——爱得那么深、那么强烈、那么彻底，以至于家里其他人根本无法理解。
There's a promise of summer, the hope we have of all things getting easier, of more fun, more free time. And then there's the reality of all we have to do to make summer live up to its potential.
夏天有一个承诺，我们希望一切都会变得更容易，会有更多的乐趣，更多的空闲时间。然后是现实，我们必须做的一切才能让夏天发挥出它的潜力。
But didn't they install little bags or something?
但他们没安装什么小袋子之类的东西吗？
Well, yeah, my brothers did, actually, when we were, like, two and a half weeks into this road trip that we took. They decided all of a sudden that we were going to have puke drills and that we needed to prepare for them like an Olympic team. And so they strategically placed plastic and paper bags all over the place but also had this blanket that they had set up that you could quick pull out. And it would drape across my lap, because I had a problem controlling where it went as well. And also, then, somebody was in charge of opening all the windows. And the other person was in charge of keeping me off their stuff.
嗯，是的，我弟弟们确实这么做了，当我们那次公路旅行进行了大约两周半的时候。他们突然决定我们要进行“呕吐演习”，并且我们需要像奥林匹克队一样为之做好准备。于是他们战略性地在各处放置了塑料袋和纸袋，还准备了一条毯子，可以快速拉出来。它会覆盖在我的腿上，因为我在控制呕吐物去向方面也有问题。而且，当时有人负责打开所有的窗户。另一个人负责让我远离他们的东西。
And did this work?
这管用吗？
No, no. It's chaos when it happens. Because that was the problem. I could never give ample enough warning to really set the whole thing in motion. Because I'd be threatening to do it for, like, three hours. And then everyone would just stop paying attention to me. And then, all of a sudden, it would just happen.
不，不。当它发生时就是一场灾难。因为问题就在这儿。我从来无法给出足够的预警来真正启动这一切。因为我可能会威胁要吐，大概有三个小时。然后大家就会停止关注我了。然后，突然之间，它就发生了。
So pretty much, any summer vacation for you is pretty much a bust.
所以对你来说，基本上任何暑假都是一场空。
Yes. I hate summer.
是的。我讨厌夏天。
You actually hate summer?
你真的讨厌夏天？
Oh, totally, because of the expectations that you're supposed to have a good time, like, your life is supposed to be like a Pepsi commercial or something. And you're supposed to have this great time and because the weather's nice, you're supposed to go to the beach. And because the weather's nice, you're supposed to go to outdoor concerts and have fun and be happy all the time. And you're not supposed to sit in your house and watch TV and get upset. It's just terrible.
哦，完全讨厌，因为人们期望你应该玩得开心，就像你的生活应该像百事可乐的广告一样。你应该过得很愉快，因为天气很好，你就应该去海滩。因为天气很好，你就应该去参加户外音乐会，玩得开心，一直快乐。你不应该坐在家里看电视，感到难过。这简直太糟糕了。
And you're supposed to have a boyfriend or a girlfriend. It's just awful. It's an awful, terrible time of the year. Nobody wants you to be happy in the winter. You have no pressure to be happy. You can just be whatever you want. You can feel totally justified in being depressed.
而且你应该有一个男朋友或女朋友。这太可怕了。这是一年中可怕、糟糕的时间。冬天没人要求你快乐。你没有压力去快乐。你可以随心所欲。你可以感到抑郁也是完全合理的。
But in the summer, it's awful. Everyone wants you to be all happy. And then you just feel like a loser. So you're not even really that depressed about anything in particular other than the fact that you're just like, I kind of just feel like a loser.
但在夏天，这太可怕了。每个人都希望你一直快乐。然后你只会觉得自己是个失败者。所以你甚至没有因为什么特别的事情而感到抑郁，除了这样一个事实：你只是觉得，我感觉自己像个失败者。
The way you're describing it, summer is just like a three-month-long prom date, where you're supposed to go and have a good time, but nobody ever does.
照你这么描述，夏天就像一场长达三个月的毕业舞会约会，你应该去玩得开心，但从来没人玩得开心。
Exactly. I think that's exactly what summer is. Exactly. You feel like such a sucker. But you can't really get out of it.
没错。我觉得夏天就是这样。完全没错。你觉得自己像个傻瓜。但你真的没法摆脱它。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, with Memorial Day here, a show about the promise of summer. And this hour on our show, we're going to try something different. Usually, those who are familiar with the show know that we will choose one theme and bring you a variety of all different kinds of stories over the course of the hour. Today, we're going to hear two stories interlaced throughout the hour-- one from Ron Carlson, one from Scott Carrier. We'll hear those stories in a minute. But first, a little mood music.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，我是艾拉·格拉斯，节目是《美国生活》。今天在我们的节目中，随着阵亡将士纪念日的到来，我们将带来一期关于夏天承诺的节目。在这一小时的节目中，我们将尝试一些不同的东西。通常，熟悉我们节目的听众知道，我们会选择一个主题，并在这一小时内为您带来各种各样的故事。今天，我们将听到两个故事穿插其中——一个来自罗恩·卡尔森，一个来自斯科特·卡里尔。我们稍后会听到这些故事。但首先，来点烘托气氛的音乐。
[MUSIC--"WHO LOVES THE SUMMER" BY VELVET UNDERGROUND]
[音乐——地下丝绒乐队的《谁爱夏天》]
Well, Act One and Two. Most of our ideas about the start of summer come from school, from that moment when we would get out of school in May or June and feel that flush of freedom. Even as adults, I think we yearn for that feeling to hit us again come Memorial Day, come the start of summer. The first of these two stories that we'll be hearing interlaced throughout the hour is by Ron Carlson, a story of somebody on summer break from college. Ron Carlson is a writer who lives in Arizona.
好了，第一幕和第二幕。我们对夏季开始的大部分想法都来自学校，来自我们在五月或六月放学时感受到那股自由激流的时刻。即使作为成年人，我想我们也渴望在阵亡将士纪念日到来、夏季开始时，再次感受到那种感觉。我们将在这一小时内穿插听到的这两个故事中的第一个，是由罗恩·卡尔森讲述的，一个关于某人在大学暑假期间的故事。罗恩·卡尔森是一位住在亚利桑那州的作家。
In 1967, the year before the year that finally cracked the 20th century once and for all, I had as my summer job delivering medical oxygen in Phoenix, Arizona. I was a sophomore at the University of Montana in Missoula, but my parents lived in Phoenix and my father, as welding engineer, used his contacts to get me a job at Air and Oxygen Company. I started there doing what I called "dumbbell maintenance," the kind of make work that's assigned to college kids. I cleared debris from the back lot, mainly crushed packing crates.
1967年，那是最终彻底改变20世纪那一年的前一年，我的暑期工作是在亚利桑那州凤凰城运送医用氧气。我是蒙大拿大学米苏拉分校的大二学生，但我父母住在凤凰城，我父亲作为一名焊接工程师，利用他的人脉为我在空气与氧气公司找了一份工作。我刚开始在那里做所谓的“笨蛋维护”，就是那种分配给大学生的杂活。我清理后院的碎片，主要是压碎的包装板条箱。
These were good days for me. I was 19 years old, and this was the hardest work I had ever done. The days were stunning, starting hot and growing insistently hotter. My first week, two of the days had been 116. And in that first week, I learned what not to touch, where not to stand. And I found the powerhouse heat simply bracing. I lost some of the winter dormitory fat and could feel myself browning and getting into shape.
那是我美好的日子。我19岁，这是我做过的最艰苦的工作。那些日子真是令人惊叹，从炎热开始，并且变得愈发炎热。第一周，有两天是116华氏度。在那第一周里，我学会了什么不能碰，哪里不能站。我发现那股强劲的热浪简直让人精神振奋。我减掉了一些宿舍生活带来的冬季脂肪，能感觉到自己变黑了，身体也变好了。
I was having a hard ride through the one relationship I had begun during the school year. Her name was Linda Enright, a classmate, and we had made the mistake of sleeping together that spring. Just once, but it wrecked absolutely everything. We were dreamy beforehand, the kind of couple who walked real close, bumping foreheads. We read each other's papers. I'm not making this up. We read poetry on the library lawn under a tree.
我在学校期间开始的一段恋情经历了一段艰难的时期。她叫琳达·恩赖特，是我的同学，那年春天我们犯了个错，睡在了一起。就一次，但那彻底毁了一切。在此之前我们如梦似幻，是那种走得很近、额头相碰的情侣。我们互相阅读对方的论文。我没开玩笑。我们在图书馆草坪的树下读诗。
And then, one night in her dorm room, we went ahead with it, squirming out of our clothing on her hard bed. And we did something for about a minute that changed everything. After that, we weren't even the same people. She wasn't she, and I wasn't I. We were too young citizens in the wrong country. All I could remember from the incident itself was Linda stopping once and undoing my belt and saying, here, I'll get it.
然后，有一天晚上在她的宿舍房间里，我们继续了下去，在她的硬床上脱掉了衣服。在那一分钟左右的时间里，我们做了一件事，改变了一切。之后，我们甚至不再是同一个人了。她不再是她，我也不再是我。我们是错乱国度里两个太年轻的公民。关于这件事，我唯一能记住的就是琳达停下来解开我的皮带说，来吧，我帮你。
The coolness of that practical phrase repeated in my mind after I'd said goodbye to Linda and she'd gone off to Boulder where her summer job was working in her parents' cookie shop. I called her every Sunday from a pay phone at an Exxon station on Indian School Road, and we'd fight. And if you asked me what we fought about, I couldn't tell you. We both felt misunderstood.
在我和琳达道别，她去了博尔德她父母开的饼干店做暑期工之后，那句实用话语的冷静感在我的脑海中反复回荡。我每个星期天都会从印第安学校路的一家埃克森加油站用公用电话给她打电话，然后我们会吵架。如果你问我我们吵什么，我说不上来。我们都感到被误解了。
Ron Carlson. Let's start the second of the two stories we'll hear throughout this hour. This is a very different kind of summer adventure, one spent outside with nature. Scott Carrier, a frequent contributor to This American Life, decided to canoe down the Green River in Utah.
罗恩·卡尔森。让我们开始这一小时内我们将听到的两个故事中的第二个。这是一个非常不同类型的夏季冒险，一个与大自然相处的户外活动。斯科特·卡里尔，一位《美国生活》的常客，决定划独木舟沿犹他州的绿河而下。
I have to confess a profound ignorance about what I'm doing. My preparation for this float trip consisted of buying a canoe and then grabbing a Wyoming road map from a rest stop on the drive up. I'd been in a canoe a couple of times, and I thought I knew how to make it turn and go straight. And I'd seen the river from several bridges I'd crossed on other trips in other years. And it was always wide and calm and flat. So I thought I could manage well enough.
我必须承认，对于我在做什么，我有着深刻的无知。我这次漂流旅行的准备工作就是买了一艘独木舟，然后在开车前往的路上在休息站顺手拿了一张怀俄明州的公路地图。我曾划过几次独木舟，我以为我知道怎么让它转向和直行。而且我在往年的其他旅行中，曾从我经过的几座桥上看过这条河。它总是宽阔、平静且平坦。所以我以为我能应付得来。
I could have practiced with the canoe, gone out with someone who could show me the strokes. And I could have read up on the river, learned about what was in store for me. But I chose not to do these things. When you try to lay things out, try to control what's going to happen, you always end up disappointed or frustrated. At least I do. My first surprise has been that the river, at the top, was not calm and flat. There were rapids-- big rapids. I floated down and camped where I first heard the roar. It sounded like this.
我本可以练习划独木舟，和能教我划桨技巧的人一起出去。我本可以阅读一些关于这条河的资料，了解等待我的是什么。但我选择了不做这些事情。当你试图安排好一切，试图控制将要发生的事情时，你总是会感到失望或沮丧。至少我是这样。我的第一个意外是，这条河在源头处并不平静和平坦。那里有急流——巨大的急流。我漂流而下，在我第一次听到轰鸣声的地方扎了营。它听起来像这样。
[SOUND OF ROARING RIVER]
[咆哮的河流声]
This sound was carried on the wind to my tent off and on through the night. And it rained with lightning and thunder. I got up with the sun, made some coffee, and prepared for the worst. I double- and triple- wrapped everything in garbage bags and tied it all into the canoe. And then I took off my clothes. It would be easier to swim naked. And if I was to drown, I wanted, for some reason, to drown naked.
这个声音整夜断断续续地随风传到我的帐篷里。还下了雨，伴随着闪电和雷声。我和太阳一起起床，煮了些咖啡，为最坏的情况做好了准备。我把所有东西用垃圾袋包了两三层，并把它们全部绑在独木舟里。然后我脱掉了衣服。裸体游泳会更容易。如果我要淹死，出于某种原因，我希望赤身裸体地淹死。
I started down the river, praying for all the ants I'd ever stepped on, for all the bugs that had splattered into my windshield. I prayed for dirt and discarded things. I prayed for all my forgotten memories. And somehow, I made it. The canoe kept filling with water, but it stayed upright. And I got away with only a couple of welts on my shins.
我开始顺流而下，为我曾经踩死过的所有蚂蚁祈祷，为所有撞在我的挡风玻璃上的昆虫祈祷。我为尘土和被丢弃的东西祈祷。我为我所有被遗忘的记忆祈祷。不知何故，我成功了。独木舟一直往里进水，但它保持了直立。我只在小腿上留下了几个肿块。
Two weeks into the summer, I was drafted to drive one of the two medical oxygen trucks. One of the drivers had quit, and our foreman came out on the dock in the morning and told me to see Nadine, who ran medical, in her little office building out front. They had the truck loaded. Two groups of 10 medical-blue cylinders chain hitched into the front of the bed. These tanks were going to be in people's bedrooms.
暑假过两周后，我被征召去开两辆医用氧气卡车中的一辆。其中一名司机辞职了，我们的领班早上来到码头上，让我去见前面小办公室里负责医用物资的娜丁。他们已经装好了卡车。两组10个医用蓝色气瓶用链子拴在车斗前部。这些罐子将要被送到人们的卧室里。
I climbed in the truck and started it up, pulled onto McDowell, and headed for Sun City. At that time, Sun City was set alone in the desert, a weird theme park for retired white people. And from the beginning, it gave me an eerie feeling. The streets were like toy streets, narrow and clean, running in large circles. No cars, no garage doors open, and, of course, in the heat, no pedestrians.
我爬上卡车发动起来，开到麦克道尔路上，前往太阳城。那时，太阳城独自坐落在沙漠中，是一个为退休白人准备的古怪主题公园。从一开始，它就给我一种阴森的感觉。街道就像玩具街道一样，狭窄而干净，绕成一个个大圆圈。没有车，没有开着的车库门，当然，在高温下，也没有行人。
These people had come here from the Midwest and the East. They had been doctors and professors and lawyers and wanted to live among their own kind. No one under 20 could reside in Sun City.
这些人是从中西部和东部来到这里的。他们曾是医生、教授和律师，想和自己同类的人生活在一起。20岁以下的人不得居住在太阳城。
Mr. Rensdale was the first of my customers I ever saw in bed. I rang the bell and was met by a young woman in a long silk shirt, who saw me and said, "Oh, yeah. Come on in." I had the hot, blue cylinder on the single dolly and pulled it up the step and into the dark, cool space. I had my pocket rag and wiped the wheels as soon as she shut the door. I pointed down the hall. "Is it this way?"
兰斯代尔先生是我见过的第一个躺在床上的客户。我按了门铃，出来迎接我的是一位穿着长丝绸衬衫的年轻女子，她看见我就说：“哦，对了。进来吧。”我用单轮手推车拉着那个又热又蓝的钢瓶，把它拉上台阶，进入阴凉的空间。她一关门，我就拿出我的口袋抹布擦拭轮子。我指着走廊说：“是这边吗？”
"No, upstairs. First door on  your right. He's awake, David." She said my name just the way you read names off shirts. Then she put her hand on my sleeve and said, "Who hit you?"
“不，在楼上。右手边第一扇门。大卫，他醒着呢。”她读我名字的语调就像从衬衫上读名字一样。然后她把手放在我的袖子上说：“谁打你了？”
My old scar was still raw across my cheekbone. "I got burned."
我脸颊上方的旧伤疤还在发炎。“我烫伤了。”
"Cute," she said. "They're going to love that back at where?"
“可爱，”她说。“在……什么地方，人们会喜欢那个？”
"University of Montana."
“蒙大拿大学。”
"University of what?" She said. "There's a university there?" She smiled. "I'm kidding. I'm a snob, but I'm kidding. What year are you?"
“什么大学？”她说。“那里有大学吗？”她微笑着。“我开玩笑呢。我是个势利眼，但我开玩笑呢。你几年级？”
I'll be a junior, "I said."
“我要读大三了，”我说。
"I'm a senior at Penn," she said.
“我是宾大的大四学生，”她说。
I nodded, my mind whipping around for something clever. I didn't even know where Penn was. "Great," I said. I started up the stairs.
我点点头，脑子飞快地转动着想找点聪明的回答。我甚至不知道宾大在哪里。“太好了，”我说。我开始上楼。
"Yeah," she said. "Great."
“是啊，”她说。“太好了。”
I drew the dolly up the carpeted stair carefully and entered the bedroom. It was dim in there, but I could see the other cylinder beside the bed and a man in the bed, awake. He was wearing pajamas and immediately upon seeing me said, "Good. Open the blinds, will you?"
我小心翼翼地把手推车拉上铺着地毯的楼梯，走进卧室。里面光线很暗，但我可以看到床边有另一个钢瓶，床上躺着一个人，醒着。他穿着睡衣，一看到我就说：“好。帮我把百叶窗打开，行吗？”
"Sure thing," I said, and I went around the bed and turned the mini blind wand. The Arizona day fell into the room. The young woman I'd spoken to walked out to the pool beneath me. She took off her shirt and hung it on one of the chairs. Her breasts were white in the sunlight. She set out her magazine and drink by one of the lounges and lay face down in a shiny, green bikini bottom. I only looked for a second or less, but I could feel the image in my body.
“没问题，”我说，我绕到床边转动迷你百叶窗的拨杆。亚利桑那州的日光落入房间。我刚才和她说话的那位年轻女子走到我下方的游泳池边。她脱下衬衫，挂在椅子上。她的胸部在阳光下呈现出白色。她把杂志和饮料放在躺椅旁，穿着一条闪亮的绿色比基尼下装脸朝下躺着。我只看了一秒钟不到，但我能感觉到那个影像印在我的身体里。
While I was disconnecting the regulator from the old tank and setting up the new one, Mr. Rensdale introduced himself. He was a thin, handsome man, with dark hair and mustache. And he looked like about three or four of the actors I was seeing those nights in late movies after my parents went to bed. I liked him immediately.
当我在断开旧气瓶的调节器并安装新气瓶时，兰斯代尔先生做了自我介绍。他是一个瘦削、英俊的男人，留着深色头发和胡子。他看起来像我在父母睡觉后看的深夜电影里见过的三四个演员。我立刻就喜欢上了他。
"What field are you in?" I asked him. He seemed so absolutely worldly there, his wry eyes and his East Coast accent. And he seemed old the way people did then. But I realized now he wasn't 50.
“你是哪个领域的？”我问他。他在那里显得如此从容世故，带着戏谑的眼神和东海岸的口音。而且他看起来像当时的人一样老。但我现在意识到他还没50岁。
"I, lad, am the owner of Rensdale Foundations, which my father founded." His whisper was rich with humor. "We make ladies undergarments. Lots of them."
“孩子，我是兰斯代尔基金会的拥有者，那是我父亲创立的。”他的耳语中充满了幽默。“我们制作女士内衣。很多很多。”
The dolly was loaded and I was ready to go.
手推车装好了，我准备走了。
"Come after 4:00 next time if it's worth a martini to you, kid. And we'll do some career counseling."
“下次如果在4点以后来，如果你想喝杯马提尼，孩子。我们会聊聊职业规划。”
He gave me a thin smile and I left. Letting myself out of the dark downstairs, I did an odd thing. I stood still in the house. I had talked to her right here. I saw her breasts again in the bright light. No one knew where I was.
他给了我一个淡淡的微笑，我离开了。当我走出阴暗的楼下时，我做了一件奇怪的事。我静静地站在房子里。我刚才就在这里和她说过话。我又看到了她在明亮光线下的胸部。没人知道我在哪里。
The next house was an old block home gone to seed-- the lawn dirt, the shrubs dead, the windows brown with dust and cobwebs. I was fairly sure I had a wrong address and that the property was abandoned. I knocked on the greasy door, and after five minutes, a stooped, red-haired old man answered. This was Gil, and I have no idea how old he was that summer, but it was as old as you get. His skin, stretched tight and translucent on his gaunt body, was splattered with brown spots. On his hand, several had been picked raw.
下一所房子是一座破败的砖房——草坪全是泥土，灌木枯死，窗户上覆盖着灰尘和蜘蛛网。我相当确定我地址错了，而且这处房产已经废弃了。我敲了敲油腻的门，五分钟后，一个弯腰驼背、红头发的老人开了门。这是吉尔，我不知道那个夏天他有多大岁数，但他就是你所能见到的那么老。他那消瘦的身体上绷着又薄又透明的皮肤，溅满了棕色的斑点。在他的手上，有几处已经被抠破了。
I pulled my dolly into the house and was hit by the roiling smell of dog hair and urine. I didn't kneel to wipe the wheels.
我把手推车拉进屋子，立刻被狗毛和尿液翻涌的臭味袭击了。我没有跪下来擦轮子。
"Right in here," the old man said, leading me back into the house toward a yellow light in the small kitchen where I could hear a radio chattering. He had his oxygen set up in the corner of the kitchen. It looked like he lived in the one room. There was a fur of fine, red dust on everything-- the range, the sink-- except half the kitchen table where he had his things arranged. I got busy changing out the tanks. Meanwhile, the old man sat down at the kitchen table and started talking.
“就在这里，”老人说着，把我带进屋子，走向小厨房里一盏黄色的灯光下，我能听到收音机里传来的声音。他的氧气设备就设置在厨房角落里。看起来他住在这个房间里。除了他摆放东西的那半张餐桌外，所有东西——炉灶、水槽——上都覆盖着一层细细的红尘。我忙着更换罐子。与此同时，老人在餐桌旁坐下，开始说话。
"I'm Gil Benson," his speech began, "and I'm glad to see you, David. My lungs got burned in France in 1919, and it took them 20 years to buckle." He spoke, like so many of my customers, in a hoarse whisper. "I've lived all over the world, including the three As-- Africa, Australia, and Alaska. My favorite place was Montreal, Canada, because I was in love there and married the woman, had children. My least favorite place is right here because of this.
“我是吉尔·本森，”他的话开始了，“很高兴见到你，大卫。我的肺是1919年在法国烧伤的，花了20年才彻底垮掉。”他说话时像我许多客户一样，带着沙哑的低语。“我去过世界各地，包括三个A——非洲、澳大利亚和阿拉斯加。我最喜欢的地方是加拿大的蒙特利尔，因为我在那里恋爱了，娶了那个女人，有了孩子。我最不喜欢的地方就是这儿，因为这个。”
"One of my closest friends was Jack Kramer, the tennis player. That was many years ago. I've flown every plane made between the years 1928 and 1948. I don't fly anymore with all this." He indicated the oxygen equipment. "Sit down. Have a cookie."
“我最亲密的朋友之一是网球运动员杰克·克莱默。那是很多年前的事了。1928年到1948年间制造的每一种飞机我都开过。有了这些，我就不再飞了。”他指了指氧气设备。“坐下。吃块饼干。”
I had my dolly ready. "I shouldn't, sir," I said. "I've got a schedule and better keep it."
我准备好了手推车。“我不应该吃，先生，”我说。“我有时间表，最好遵守它。”
"Grab that pitcher out of the fridge before you sit down. I made us some Kool-Aid. It's good."
“在你坐下之前，从冰箱里拿那个水罐。我做了些酷爱饮料。很好喝。”
I opened his refrigerator. Except for the Tupperware pitcher, it was empty. Nothing. I put the pitcher on the table. "I really have to go," I said. "I'll be late."
我打开了他的冰箱。除了那个特百惠水罐，里面空空如也。什么都没有。我把水罐放在桌上。“我真的得走了，”我说。“我会迟到的。”
"Sit down," he said. "This is your last stop today. Have a snack."
“坐下，”他说。“这是你今天最后一站。吃个点心。”
So began my visits with the old Gil Benson. He was my last delivery every fourth day that summer. And as far as I could tell, I was the only one to visit his wretched house. On one occasion, I placed one of the Oreos he gave me on the corner of my chair as I left, and it was there next time when I returned. Our visits became little three-part dramas-- my arrival and the bustle of intrusion, the snack and his monologue, his hysteria and weeping. I had "I've got to go" all over my face, but he would never read it.
就这样，我开始了与老吉尔·本森的探访。那个夏天每四天，他都是我的最后一站。据我所知，我是唯一一个访问他那破烂房子的人。有一次，我离开时把给我的奥利奥饼干放在椅子的角落里，下次回来时它还在那儿。我们的访问变成了三个部分的短剧——我的到来和闯入的忙乱，吃点心和他的独白，他的歇斯底里和哭泣。我的脸上写满了“我得走了”，但他从不读出来。
It always started with the story of long ago, an airplane, a homemade repair, an emergency landing, an odd coincidence, each part told with pride. But his voice would gradually change, slide into a kind of whine as he began an escalating series of complaints about his doctors, the insurance, his children, naming each of the four and relating their indifference, petty greed or cruelty.
这总是从很久以前的故事开始，一架飞机，一次自制修理，一次紧急迫降，一次奇特的巧合，每一部分都讲述得带着自豪感。但他的声音会逐渐改变，滑向一种哀鸣，因为他开始了一系列关于医生、保险、孩子们的抱怨，点出四个孩子中的每一个，诉说他们的冷漠、小气或残忍。
I nodded through all of this. I've got to go. I'd slide my chair back and he'd grab my wrist. By then, I could understand his children pushing him away and moving out of state. I wanted out.
我点头听着这一切。我得走了。我会把椅子往后拉，他就会抓住我的手腕。到那时，我能理解他的孩子们为什么要把他推开搬到外州去。我想要离开。
It's been easy floating the past couple of days. But the river winds back and forth in these big, long S-turns. And sometimes, I paddle maybe 10 miles to cover just one as the crow flies. Yesterday, at sunset, after a long, hot day, I pulled out and camped in a grassy field. I could see a ranch house about a mile in the distance. So the thought of being on private property did cross my mind. But like I say, the house was a mile away, and it was late.
过去几天漂流很容易。但河流在这些巨大的长S弯中来回蜿蜒。有时我划了大约10英里，直线距离却只走了一英里。昨天日落时分，经过漫长而炎热的一天，我靠岸在草地上露营。我能看到远处约一英里处有一座牧场房子。所以这确实让我想到了是在私人土地上。但就像我说的，房子在一英里外，而且天色已晚。
This morning I unzipped the tent, and the grass was covered with frost. My shoes, which I had left outside, were frozen stiff. So I got up slowly and just laid around until 10:00 or 11:00 looking at the scenery. I saw moose and beaver, bald eagles, Sandhill cranes, and many little birds I don't know by name. There was a little one in the willows by the river, and it was bright orange and yellow, like a parakeet you might buy in a pet store.
今天早上我拉开帐篷拉链，草地上覆盖着霜。我放在外面的鞋子冻得硬邦邦的。所以我慢慢起来，一直闲逛到10点或11点，看着风景。我看到了驼鹿和海狸、秃鹰、沙丘鹤，还有许多我叫不出名字的小鸟。在河边的柳树丛中有一只小鸟，它是明亮的橙色和黄色，就像你在宠物店买的长尾鹦鹉一样。
So I was lying around thinking what a great place it was when a truck drove up and parked on a dirt road about a quarter mile away. And a man, a ranch foreman, Chuck Davis, came over to chew me out.
所以我正躺着想这是个多么好的地方，这时一辆卡车开了过来，停在约四分之一英里外的土路上。一个男人，牧场领班查克·戴维斯，走过来训斥我。
Mrs. Kellen called me up and asked me to come down and please ask you to leave, which I have. The Kellens make their living-- or the operation of this ranch comes from selling hay that you're laying on right now. The ground that you've knocked down this side of the river is irrigating right now. You can look out there just 10 feet away from you and there's water. They're irrigating this, trying to put this up as hay.
“凯伦太太打电话叫我下来，请你离开，我已经这么做了。凯伦一家维持生计——或者说这个牧场的运营来自销售你现在躺着上面的干草。你在这个河岸边踩坏的土地现在正在灌溉。你从这里往外看，离你不到10英尺就有水。他们正在灌溉这里，试图把它种成干草。”
Do you have a lot of trouble with people trespassing?
你们经常遇到人们擅自闯入的问题吗？
Yes, we do, at specific times of the year. Hell, I'm a hunter and a fisherman, a sportsman. And I like to go, when I get the time, to hunt and fish myself. But these people have paid a specific amount of money, and it's a large amount of money. They pay a large amount of taxes every year on this ground. And it's their right to say who comes and who goes on that property.
“是的，每年特定的时间都有。见鬼，我也是猎人和渔民，一个体育爱好者。我有时间的时候也喜欢去狩猎和钓鱼。但这些人付了一笔特定的钱，而且是一大笔钱。他们每年在这块土地上缴纳大量的税款。他们有权决定谁来这里，谁走这里。”
Why do you have to come here? There's ground up there too for the public. From the Green River Lakes, there's millions and millions of acres of public ground, of national forest, of state ground. Why do you have to come on this specific piece of ground?
“你为什么非要来这儿？上面也有给公众用的土地。从绿河湖出发，有数百万英亩的公共土地，国家森林，州立土地。你为什么非要来这块特定的土地？”
It looked nice. [LAUGHS]
看起来不错。[笑]
Yeah, how long will it stay nice? How long will it continue to look nice if everybody comes down here-- and I'm not pointing a finger at you-- but if 10 people come through here and nine of them leave beer cans-- or even four of them-- every day, or build different fires and the fire ring is here, how long will this look nice? You've just got to draw the line somewhere.
“是啊，它能好多久？如果每个人都来这里——我不是指着你——但如果每天有10个人经过这里，其中9个人留下啤酒罐——或者哪怕4个人——或者建造不同的火堆，火圈就在这儿，这看起来还能好多久？你总得在某处划清界限。”
I apologized for my trespass and was quickly back on the river, paddling through some of the most beautiful country I'd ever seen and keeping my eye on both banks, the two lines I wouldn't cross again until sometime after dark.
我为我的擅自闯入道歉，并迅速回到河上，划过我见过的一些最美丽的乡村，并盯着两岸，这是我直到天黑后才会再次跨越的两条线。
By mid-July, I had become tight and fit. I looked like a young boxer, and I tried not to think about anything. Backing up to the loading dock late on those days with a trunk of empties, I was full of animal happiness. And I moved with the measured deliberation the full day had given me. When I bent to the metal fountain beside the dock, gulping the water, I could feel it bloom on my back and my chest and come out along my hairline.
七月中旬，我变得紧实健壮。我看起来像个年轻的拳击手，并且尽量不去想任何事情。那些日子深夜背靠着卸货码头，车里装满了空罐子，我充满了动物般的快乐。我带着漫长一天赋予我的那种深思熟虑的从容移动。当我弯腰去喝码头旁边的金属喷泉水时，我能感觉到它在我的背部和胸部绽放，并沿着发际线流出。
Around this time, a terrible thing happened in my phone correspondence with Linda Enright. We stopped fighting. We'd talk about her family. The cookie business was taking off, but her father wouldn't let her take the car. He was stingy. I told her about my deliveries, the heat.
大约在这个时候，我和琳达·恩赖特的电话通信中发生了一件可怕的事。我们停止了争吵。我们会谈论她的家人。饼干生意正在起步，但她父亲不让她开车。他很吝啬。我告诉她我的送货情况，那些炎热。
As I listened to us talk, I stood and wondered, "Who are these people?" The other me wanted to interrupt to ask, "Hey, didn't we have sex? I mean, was that sexual intercourse? Isn't the world a little different for you now?" But I chatted with her. When the operator came on, I was crazy with Linda's indifference but unable to say anything but, "Take care. I'll call."
当我听着我们谈话时，我站着想，“这些人是谁？”另一个我想要打断，问：“嘿，我们没发生过性关系吗？我是说，那是性交吗？现在的世界对你来说没有一点不同吗？”但我只是和她闲聊。当接线员进来时，我对琳达的冷漠感到疯狂，却什么也说不出来，只能说，“保重。我会再打给你。”
Meanwhile, the summer assumed a regularity that was nothing but comfort. I drove my routes. I was used to sitting with Gil Benson and hearing his stories, pocketing the Oreos secretly to throw them from the truck later. I was used to Elizabeth Rensdale showing me her white breasts, posturing by the pool whenever she knew I was upstairs with her father.
与此同时，夏天呈现出一种除了舒适别无他物的规律。我驾驶我的路线。我习惯了和吉尔·本森坐在一起听他的故事，偷偷把奥利奥放进口袋，稍后再从卡车里扔掉。我习惯了伊丽莎白·兰斯代尔只要知道我在楼上和她父亲在一起时，就在游泳池旁向我展示她白皙的胸部，摆姿势。
Driving the valley those long summer days, each window of the truck a furnace, listening to "Paperback Writer" and "Last Train to Clarksville," I delivered oxygen to the paralyzed and dying. And I felt so alive and on edge at every moment that I could've burst. I liked the truck, hopping up, unloading the hot cylinders at each address, and then driving to the next stop. I knew what I was doing and wanted no more.
在漫长的夏日里开着车穿过山谷，卡车的每扇窗户都像火炉，听着《平装书作家》和《开往克拉克斯维尔的末班车》，我为瘫痪和垂死的人运送氧气。我觉得自己如此鲜活，每一刻都处于边缘，几乎要迸发出来。我喜欢这辆卡车，跳上去，在每个地址卸下滚烫的气瓶，然后开车去下一站。我知道我在做什么，别无所求。
Rain broke the summer. The second week in August, I woke to the first clouds in 90 days. They massed and thickened. And by the time I left Sun City, it had begun, a crashing downpour. I didn't want to be late at the Rensdales. I was wiping down the tank in the covered entry when Elizabeth opened the door and disappeared back into the dark house. I was wet from the warm rain, and coming into the air-conditioned house ran a chill along my sides. When my eyes adjusted and I started backing up the stairway with a new cylinder, I saw Elizabeth sitting on the couch in the den, her knees together up under her chin, watching me. She was looking right at me.
雨打破了夏天。八月的第二周，我醒来时看到了90天以来的第一朵云。它们聚集并变厚。当我离开太阳城时，雨就开始了，一场倾盆大雨。我不想在兰斯代尔家迟到。我正在带顶棚的入口处擦拭罐子，伊丽莎白打开门，退回了阴暗的房子里。我被温暖的雨淋湿了，进入空调房时，一阵寒意顺着我的侧身跑过。当我的眼睛适应了光线，开始带着新钢瓶后退着上楼梯时，我看到伊丽莎白坐在书房的沙发上，膝盖并拢抬到下巴下，看着我。她正盯着我。
"This is the worst summer of my entire life," she said.
“这是我一生中最糟糕的夏天，”她说。
"Sorry?" I said, coming down a step, "What'd you say?"
“抱歉？”我说，走下台阶，“你说什么？”
"David, is that you?" Mr. Rensdale called from his room. His voice was a ghost. I liked him very much, and it had become clear over the summer that he was not going back to Pennsylvania.
“大卫，是你吗？”兰斯代尔先生从他的房间叫道。他的声音像个鬼魂。我非常喜欢他，整个夏天很明显，他不会回宾夕法尼亚州了。
Elizabeth Rensdale whispered across the room to me, "I don't want to be here." She closed her eyes and rocked her head. I stood the cylinder on the dolly and went over to her. I didn't like leaving it there on the carpet. She was sitting in her underpants on the couch.
伊丽莎白·兰斯代尔隔着房间对我耳语：“我不想待在这儿。”她闭上眼睛，摇着头。我把钢瓶立在手推车上，走过去找她。我不喜欢把它留在地毯上。她只穿着内裤坐在沙发上。
"He's dying," she said to me.
“他快死了，”她对我说。
"Oh," I said, trying to make it simply a placeholder, let her know I'd heard her. She put her face in her hands and lay over on the couch. I dropped to a knee, and putting my hand on her shoulder, I said, "What can I do?"
“哦，”我说，试图让它仅仅作为一个占位符，让她知道我听到了。她把脸埋在手里，躺在沙发上。我单膝跪下，把手放在她的肩膀上说：“我能做什么？”
This was the secret side that I had suspected from this summer. Elizabeth Rensdale put her hand on mine and turned her face to mine so slowly that I felt my heart drop a gear, grinding now heavily uphill in my chest. Mr. Rensdale called my name again. Elizabeth's face on mine, so close and open, made it possible for me to move my hand around her back and pull her to me. It was like I knew what I was doing. I didn't take my eyes from hers when she rolled onto her back and guided me onto her.
这是我这个夏天一直怀疑的秘密一面。伊丽莎白·兰斯代尔把她的手放在我的手上，把脸转向我，速度如此之慢，以至于我觉得我的心脏掉了一个档，现在在我的胸腔里沉重地爬坡。兰斯代尔先生又叫了我的名字。伊丽莎白的脸贴在我的脸上，如此近且敞开，让我有可能把手绕到她的后背，把她拉向我。就像我知道我在做什么一样。当她翻过身平躺并引导我到她身上时，我没有把视线从她身上移开。
I wish I could get this right here, but there was no chance. We stayed together for a moment afterward, and my eyes opened and focused. She was still looking at me, holding me. And her look was simply serious. Her father called, "David?" from upstairs again, and I realize he must have been calling steadily.
我希望我能在这里把这一切弄对，但这不可能。之后我们在一起待了一会儿，我的眼睛睁开并聚焦。她还在看着我，抱着我。她的眼神单纯而严肃。她父亲又在楼上叫道：“大卫？”我意识到他一定一直在叫。
Mr. Rensdale lay white and twisted in the bed. He looked the way the dying look, his face parched and sunken, the mouth a dry orifice, his eyes little spots of water. I saw him acknowledge me with a withering look, more power than you'd think could rise from such a body. And I moved in the room deliberate with shame, avoiding his eyes.
兰斯代尔先生白着脸扭曲地躺在床上。他看起来像垂死之人的样子，脸干枯凹陷，嘴巴是一个干燥的孔洞，眼睛是两个小小的水点。我看到他用一种萎靡的眼神认出了我，那种力量超出了你想象的从这样一个身体里能发出的强度。我怀着羞耻心在房间里小心翼翼地移动，避开他的视线。
He rolled his hand in a little flip toward the bed table and his glass of water. Who knows what happened in me then? Because I stood in the little bedroom with Mr. Rensdale, and then I just rolled the dolly and the expired tank out and down the stairs. I didn't go to him. I didn't hand him the glass of water. I burned. Who would ever know what I have done?
他朝床头桌和他的水杯挥了挥手。那时候我体内发生了什么？因为我站在兰斯代尔先生那个小卧室里，然后我只是把手推车和用完的罐子滚出来，下了楼。我没去理他。我没递给他那杯水。我燃烧着。谁会知道我做了什么？
Sand Wash is way out in the Utah desert. You drive two and a half hours on a dirt road. And when you get there, it's a big canyon, a dry wash cutting down through shale stone badlands, and emptying into the Green River. The river at this point is slow and flat, the color of coffee with milk, and just about as warm.
沙洗区位于犹他州的荒漠深处。你需要在土路上开两个半小时。当你到达那里时，是一个大峡谷，一条干涸的河道穿过页岩石荒地，流入绿河。此时的河流缓慢而平坦，咖啡加牛奶的颜色，并且差不多一样暖和。
If you stand by the river, you might see a Great Blue Heron, a pair of Golden Eagles, a beaver, an otter. The river is a thin, snake-like oasis. But if you turn away from the water and look back up at the cliffs and barren plateaus, you might think you're now living on a dry, god-forsaken planet. It's just the Utah desert, close to where Rubin Farr buried his cat. Close to nowhere.
如果你站在河边，你可能会看到一只大蓝鹭、一对金雕、一只海狸、一只水獭。这条河是一个细长、像蛇一样的绿洲。但如果你背对着水，回头看看悬崖和荒芜的高原，你可能会认为你现在住在一个干燥、被上帝遗弃的星球上。这只是犹他州的沙漠，靠近鲁宾·法尔埋猫的地方。靠近虚无之地。
This desert is controlled by the Bureau of Land Management. They manage the grazing permits, and they give out 10,000 floating permits every year to people who want to make the six- or seven-day trip down through Desolation Canyon. There's a BLM ranger stationed there, where you put your boat in the water. Her name is Michelle Sturm. She's six feet tall and carries a clipboard. She checks your permit, checks your equipment-- first aid kit, extra paddles, life jacket. She jokes around, doesn't give you a hard time. And it's easy to see she's not from around here, that she's on some kind of leave of absence, hiding out in the wilderness.
这片沙漠由土地管理局控制。他们管理放牧许可证，每年向那些想进行六七天穿过荒凉峡谷旅行的人发放10000个漂流许可证。那里驻扎着一名土地管理局的护林员，在你把船放入水中地方。她叫米歇尔·斯特姆。她有六英尺高，带着一块写字板。她检查你的许可证，检查你的设备——急救箱、备用桨、救生衣。她开玩笑，不会为难你。很容易看出她不是本地人，她在某种休假中，躲在荒野里。
I came off of working with homeless for two and a half years-- mentally ill adults and single males and hungry people and low income families in downtown San Jose, California, and was really just tired and not enough joy in my life. I wanted to be in the middle of nowhere. So the first night I was at Sand Wash, I really felt at home and comfortable, and this was the right place.
“我刚做完两年的流浪者工作——加州圣何塞市中心的精神病成年人、单身男性、饥饿的人和低收入家庭，真的只是累了，生活中没有足够的快乐。我想待在荒无人烟的地方。所以我在沙洗区的第一晚，真的感觉宾至如归，很舒服，这就是正确的地方。”
And the light and the wind-- the factors that are really important and have bearing on your life are real significant factors, things you have absolutely no control over. And you can write by the moon at night. At night, these loud-- I don't know what they are-- sort of airplane-type bugs. But I don't think they're dragonflies, but something else just comes zooming in and zooming by the bedroom window and checking things out. And the bats are really fun. They come really close.
“光线和风——这些对你的生活确实重要并有影响的因素，是真正显著的因素，是你完全无法控制的事情。你可以在晚上就着月光写作。在晚上，这些响亮的——我不知道它们是什么——某种飞机式的虫子。但我不认为它们是蜻蜓，而是其他东西，只是呼啸着飞进来，呼啸着从卧室窗边经过，四处查看。蝙蝠也真的很有趣。它们靠得很近。”
And I hear boaters. And I hear people coming down the gravel road, and that's always a little apprehensive, as I don't know what they want.
“我能听到划船的人。我听到人们顺着碎石路下来，这总是有点令人担忧，因为我不知道他们想要什么。”
Are you going to go back to working with homeless people?
你打算回去做无家可归者的工作吗？
I don't think so. I don't think so. I think you need to have a strong faith and religious belief to do that kind of work. And I think I tend to see it more as a political situation rather than a religious situation. And so it just really produces more anger than saintliness or something.
我不这么认为。我不这么认为。我觉得做那种工作需要有坚定的信仰和宗教信念。而我觉得我倾向于把它更多地看作是一种政治形势，而不是宗教形势。所以它真的产生更多的愤怒，而不是圣洁之类的东西。
So you're angry.
所以你很愤怒。
Angry.
愤怒。
What are you upset about? What bothers--
你对什么感到沮丧？什么困扰——
Well, the thing that bothers you is that you and everyone you're working with is doing as much as you possibly can. And yet, you can't do enough. And someone else has asked you for something else, and you can't do it. And you learn to have to say no.
嗯，困扰你的是，你和你一起工作的所有人都正在尽你们所能。然而，你做得不够。别人又向你要求别的东西，你做不到。你学会了必须说不。
That's a pretty dismal way to operate. You don't want to have to operate always feeling your boundaries, and if I just keep stretching and stretching, I'm going to break, and so I have to protect myself so I don't break. And then I let all these people down. You see?
那是一种非常惨淡的运作方式。你不想总是必须感受你的界限来运作，如果我只是不停地延伸再延伸，我就要断了，所以我必须保护自己以免断裂。然后我让所有这些人失望了。你明白吗？
What you see are shadows in the moonlight, the mouth of the canyon, the eerie shapes of red rock walls, the figure of a tall woman walking home to bed.
你看到的是月光下的阴影，峡谷的入口，红岩墙阴森的形状，一个高个子女人走回家睡觉的身影。
Scott Carrier on the Green River in Utah.
犹他州绿河上的斯科特·卡里尔。
Coming up, finding a dead body and not finding one. In a minute, when our program continues.
接下来，发现一具尸体和没发现一具尸体。稍后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Promise of Summer.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，夏天的承诺。
And rather than bring you a big bunch of stories this hour, we're interlacing two stories throughout the hour. One from Scott Carrier traveling down the Green River in Utah. One from Ron Carlson, a short story called "Oxygen" from his new book of stories, Hotel Eden. Before we get back to this story is a quick warning to listeners that Ron Carlson's story contains adult situations. No explicit language, but adult situations that might not be right for every listener.
比起这一小时为您带来一大堆故事，我们正在交替穿插两个故事。一个来自在犹他州绿河旅行的斯科特·卡里尔。另一个来自罗恩·卡尔森，一个名为《氧气》的短篇小说，摘自他的新故事集《伊甸园酒店》。在回到这个故事之前，给听众一个小提醒，罗恩·卡尔森的故事包含成人情境。没有露骨的语言，但有一些可能并不适合每一位听众的成人情境。
So the last month of that summer, I began seeing Elisabeth Rensdale every day. I told my parents I was at the library because I wanted it to sound like a lie and have them know it was a lie. I came in after midnight. The library closed at 9:00.
所以那个夏天的最后一个月，我开始每天见到伊丽莎白·兰斯代尔。我告诉父母我在图书馆，因为我想让它听起来像个谎言，让他们知道那是个谎言。我午夜后才回来。图书馆9点关门。
Elizabeth and I were hardy and focused lovers. Knowing we had two hours, we used every minute of it, and we became experts at each other. We never went out for a Coke. We never took a break for a glass of water. We rarely spoke. There was admiration and curiosity in my touch and affection and gratitude in hers, or so I assumed. And I was pleased, even proud, at the time that there was so little need to speak.
伊丽莎白和我是一对强健而专注的恋人。知道我们有两个小时，我们利用了每一分钟，我们成了彼此的专家。我们从没出去喝过可乐。我们从没休息喝过水。我们很少说话。我的抚摸中有钦佩和好奇，她的抚摸中有感情和感激，或者我是这么认为的。那时我很高兴，甚至很自豪，因为几乎不需要说话。
Meanwhile, Gil Benson had begun clinging to me worse than ever, and those prolonged visits were full of agony and desperation. I had never had such a thing happen before. And until it did, I thought of myself as a compassionate person. I watch myself arrive at his terrible house and wheel the tank toward the door, and I search myself for compassion, the smallest shred of fellow feeling, kindness, affection, pity. But all I found was repulsion, impatience. Give me the truck keys and a job to do. I had no compassion for Gil Benson.
与此同时，吉尔·本森开始比以往任何时候都更紧地缠着我，那些冗长的探访充满了痛苦和绝望。我以前从未遇到过这种事。在遇到之前，我一直认为自己是个有同情心的人。我看着自己到达他那可怕的房子，把罐子推向门口，我在自己内心寻找同情心，哪怕一丝一毫的同情、善良、爱、怜悯。但我发现的只有排斥、不耐烦。给我卡车钥匙和一份要做的工作。我对吉尔·本森没有同情心。
The Sunday before Labor Day, I didn't call Linda Enright. In each minute of the day, Linda Enright was in my mind. I saw her there in her green sweater by her father's rolltop. We always talked about what we were wearing, and she always said the green sweater, saying it innocently, as if wearing the sweater that I'd helped pull over her head that night was of little note, a coincidence, and not the most important thing that she'd say in the whole $8 call.
劳动节前的那个星期天，我没给琳达·恩赖特打电话。每一分钟里，琳达·恩赖特都在我的脑海中。我看到她穿着绿色毛衣坐在她父亲的卷帘桌旁。我们总是谈论我们穿着什么，她总是说那件绿色毛衣，说得那么天真，仿佛穿着那晚我帮她拽过头的毛衣没什么大不了，是个巧合，而不是她在那通8美元的电话里会说的最重要的事情。
And I'd say, just Levi's and a t-shirt, hoping she'd imagine the belt, the buckle, the trouble it could all be in the dark. I saw her sitting in the afternoon shadow, maybe writing some notes in her calendar or reading, and right over there, the telephone. I could get up and hit the phone booth in less than 10 minutes and make that phone ring, have her reach for it. But I didn't. I'll let her sit there until the last sunlight rocked through the den, broke, and disappeared.
我会说，就牛仔裤和T恤，希望她能想象出皮带、扣子，它们在黑暗中可能引起的麻烦。我看到她坐在下午的阴影里，也许在日历上写些笔记或阅读，就在那边，电话。我可以在不到10分钟内起身去电话亭，让那部电话响起来，让她去接。但我没有。我让她坐在那里，直到最后一抹阳光穿过书房，破碎，消失。
The last day of my job in the summer of 1967, I thought-- and this is the truth-- I thought for the first time of what I was going to say last to Elizabeth Rensdale. I tried to imagine it, and my imagination failed. When I climbed from her bed the nights I'd gone to her, it was just that-- climbing out, dressing, and crossing to the door. She didn't get up. This wasn't Casablanca or High Noon or Captain Blood . This was getting laid in a hot summer desert town by your father's oxygen delivery man. There was no way to make it anything else.
1967年夏天我工作的最后一天，我想——这是实话——我第一次想到了最后会对伊丽莎白·兰斯代尔说些什么。我试图想象它，但我的想象力失败了。我从她床上爬起来去见她的那些晚上，就是那样——爬起来，穿衣，走到门口。她没起来。这不是《卡萨布兰卡》或《正午》或《血色船长》。这是在炎热的夏日沙漠小镇里，被你父亲的氧气运送员搞了。没法让它变成别的什么。
Some of my customers knew I was leaving and made kind remarks or shook my hand or had their wife hand me an envelope with a twenty in it. I smiled and nodded gratefully, and then turned, business-like, to the dolly and left. These were strange goodbyes because there was no question that we would ever see each other again. It had been a summer, and I had been their oxygen guy.
我的一些客户知道我要走了，说了些客气话，或者握了握我的手，或者让他们的妻子递给我一个装有20美元的信封。我感激地微笑着点头，然后转身，公事公办地走向手推车离开了。这些是奇怪的告别，因为毫无疑问，我们再也不会见到对方了。那只是一个夏天，我曾是他们的氧气送货员。
But there was more. I was young and they were ill. I stood in the bedroom doors in Sun City and said, take care. And I moved to the truck and felt something, but I couldn't even today tell you what it was. To the people who didn't know, who said, "See you next week, David," I didn't correct them. I said, "See you," and I left their homes too. It all had me on edge.
但还有更多。我年轻，他们生病。我站在太阳城的卧室门口说，保重。我走向卡车，感觉到了什么，但我今天甚至说不出那是什么。对于那些不知道的人，那些说“下周见，大卫”的人，我没纠正他们。我说，“再见”，然后我也离开了他们的家。这一切让我如坐针毡。
The rain moved in for the day, persistent and even, and the temperature stalled and hovered at about 100. I thought Gil would be pleased to see me so soon in the day. But I surprised him, knocking at the door for five full minutes before he unlocked it, looking scared. Though I had told him I would eventually be going back to college, I hadn't told him this was my last day.
雨整天持续不断，均匀地下着，气温停滞徘徊在大约100华氏度。我以为吉尔会很高兴这么早见到我。但我让他惊讶了，我敲了整整五分钟门，他才打开，看起来很害怕。尽管我告诉过他我最终会回大学，但我没告诉他这是我的最后一天。
There was no chatter right off the bat, no sitting down at the table. He just moved things out of the way as I wheeled the oxygen in and changed tanks. He stood to one side, leaning against the counter. When I finished, he made no move to keep me there, so I just kept going. At the front door, I said, "There you go. Good luck, Gil."
没有闲聊，也没有在桌边坐下。我推着氧气进来更换罐子时，他只是把东西移开。他站在一边，靠着柜台。我完成时，他没有留我的意思，所以我就继续走了。在门口，我说，“就这样了，祝你好运，吉尔。”
His name quickened him, and he came after me with short steps in his slippers. "Well, yes," he started as always. "I wouldn't need this stuff at all if I'd stayed out of the war." And he was off and cranking. But when I went outside, he followed me into the rain. "You've got to go," I told him. "It's wet out here."
他的名字让他振作起来，他穿着拖鞋迈着小步追了出来。“好吧，是的，”他像往常一样开始。“如果我不去打仗，我根本就不需要这些东西。”他开始滔滔不绝。但当我走到外面时，他跟进了雨中。“你得回去了，”我告诉他。“外面很湿。”
His wet skin in the light looked raw, the spots on his forehead brown and liquid. Under his eyes, the skin was purple. I'd let him get too close to the truck, and he grabbed the door handle.
他在光线下的湿皮肤看起来发红，额头上的斑点又棕又液态。他眼睛下方的皮肤是紫色的。我让他离卡车太近了，他抓住了车门把手。
"I wasn't sick a day in my life," he said. "Ask my wife."
“我一生中从没生过一天病，”他说。“问我妻子。”
I put my hand on his on the door handle, and I knew I wasn't going to be able to pry it off without breaking it. Gil Benson pulled the truck door open and with surprising dexterity, he stepped up into the vehicle, sitting on all my paperwork. I looked at Gil, shrunken and purple in the darkness of the cab. He looked like the victim of a fire.
我把手放在车门把手上的他的手上，我知道我不把他的手掰开就没法弄掉。吉尔·本森拉开车门，带着令人惊讶的灵巧，他跨上车，坐在我所有的文书工作上。我看着吉尔，在驾驶室的阴暗中萎缩且呈现紫色。他看起来像火灾的受害者。
"Gil," I said. "I'm late." I looked at him, but he did not look at me. He sat still, his eyes timid, frightened, smug. It was an expression you use when you want someone to hit you. I started the truck, hoping that would scare him, but he did not move. His eyes were still floating, and it looked like he was grinning, but it wasn't a grin. I kicked my door open and jumped down into the red mud and went around the front of the truck.
“吉尔，”我说。“我迟到了。”我看着他，但他没看我。他静静地坐着，眼神胆怯、恐惧、自鸣得意。那是一种你想让某人打你时会用的表情。我启动了卡车，希望那能吓到他，但他没动。他的眼睛还在漂浮，看起来像是在咧嘴笑，但那不是咧嘴笑。我踢开车门跳进红泥里，绕到卡车前面。
When I opened his door, he did not turn or look at me, which was fine with me. I lifted Gil like a bride, and he clutched me, his face wet against my face. I carried him to the front door. He was light and bony like an old bird. And I was strong, and I felt strong, but I could tell this was an insult the old man didn't need. When I stood him there, he would not let go, his hands clasped around my neck. And I peeled his hands apart carefully, easily, and I folded them back toward him so he wouldn't snag me again.
当我打开他的车门时，他没转头看我，这正合我意。我像抱新娘一样抱起吉尔，他抓住了我，脸贴着我的脸，湿漉漉的。我把他抱到前门。他像只老鸟一样轻而瘦骨嶙峋。我强壮，我感到强壮，但我能看出这是一次老人不需要的侮辱。当我把他放在那里时，他不肯松手，双手紧紧缠绕着我的脖子。我小心翼翼、轻而易举地剥开他的手，把它们折叠回他身边，这样他就不会再抓我了。
"Goodbye, Gil," I said. He was an old man alone in the desert. He did not acknowledge me.
“再见，吉尔，”我说。他是个在沙漠中孤独的老人。他没理我。
It happened in Desolation Canyon, a wilderness, a place of natural forces. But there was nothing about the river except a few easily negotiated rapids, nothing about the weather except a strong gust of wind at sunset, and nothing about the night, except the pulses of some distant heat lightning. There was nothing to explain the blue plastic ground cloth rolled around the body of a small, 16-year-old boy.
这发生在荒凉峡谷，一片荒野，自然力量之地。但除了几处容易谈判的急流，河上没有什么；除了日落时强劲的阵风，天气没什么；除了远处一些热闪电的脉冲，夜晚没什么。没什么能解释包裹着那个16岁男孩尸体的蓝色塑料地布。
This plastic, set on the floor of a rubber raft, the raft pulled up on a beach below a dirt road where the airplane would land, the young friend of the boy asleep on the sand, bleached blond hair, necklace, smooth, tense skin. A child. This man, an instructor, who came to fly the body out of the canyon.
这块放在橡胶筏地板上的塑料，筏子停在飞机着陆的土路下方的海滩上，男孩的年轻朋友在沙滩上睡着，漂白的金发、项链、光滑紧绷的皮肤。一个孩子。这个男人，一个教官，来把尸体从峡谷中运走。
The boy who died was a 16-year-old student. And he died yesterday, on the seventh day of the course. He was discovered by a fellow student at his campsite at about 10:50 PM with no apparent pulse or breathing. And cardiopulmonary resuscitation was performed for 44 minutes.
死去的男孩是一名16岁的学员。他昨天，在课程的第七天去世了。他在晚上10:50左右被同学发现倒在营地，没有明显的脉搏或呼吸。心肺复苏术进行了44分钟。
As far as you know, the death didn't have anything to do with the river or being on the river.
据你所知，死亡与河流或在河上无关。
I'm quite sure that wasn't the case.
我很确定情况并非如此。
Do you have any ideas of what was the cause?
你对死因有什么想法吗？
At this point, no, I don't. I'm sure that the coroner's report will tell us what it was, but I can't say. I couldn't speculate.
目前没有。我相信验尸报告会告诉我们是什么，但我不能说。我不能猜测。
What's it like? What's it-- I don't know how to ask that question, but what's it like when one of your students dies?
那是什么感觉？那——我不知道怎么问这个问题，但当你的一个学员死去时是什么感觉？
Traumatic, heartrending, for not only the instructors but fellow students. It's been a difficult 24 hours. It'll continue to be so.
令人创伤、心碎，不仅对教官，对同学也是如此。这是艰难的24小时。将来还会继续这样。
You know, a river has its own space and time. Earth dissolves into water, water into air. And death is like a river. You stand next to it, and all the words fall out of your head.
你知道，河流有自己的空间和时间。大地溶解在水中，水溶解在空气中。死亡就像一条河流。你站在它旁边，所有的词语都从你的脑海中掉落了。
I radioed Nadine that the rain had slowed me up, and I wouldn't make it back before 5:00.
我用无线电告诉娜丁，雨让我慢了下来，我无法在5点前赶回。
"No problem, sonny boy," she said. "Over."
“没问题，小伙子，”她说。“完毕。”
"I'll hit the Rensdales and on in. Over."
“我会去兰斯代尔家，然后结束。完毕。”
"Sonny boy," she said. "Just pick up there. Mr. Rensdale died yesterday. Remember the portable unit, OK? And good luck at school. Stop in if you're down for Christmas break. Over."
“小伙子，”她说。“就去那儿拿吧。兰斯代尔先生昨天去世了。记得带便携式装置，好吗？祝你在学校好运。如果你寒假下来，顺便过来看看。完毕。”
I waited a minute to over and out to Nadine while the news subsided in me. It was on Scottsdale Road at Camelback where I turned right. That corner will always be that radio call. "Copy. Over," I said.
我等了一会儿才回“完毕”给娜丁，消息在我内心平息。我是在驼背山的斯科茨代尔路上右转的。那个角落永远是那个无线电呼叫。“收到。完毕，”我说。
In front of the Rensdale's townhouse, I felt odd going to the door with the empty dolly. I rang the bell, and after a moment, Elizabeth appeared. She was barefoot in jeans and a t-shirt, and she looked at me.
在兰斯代尔家联排别墅前，我带着空手推车去敲门感觉很奇怪。我按了门铃，过了一会儿，伊丽莎白出现了。她赤脚穿着牛仔裤和T恤，看着我。
"I'm sorry about your father," I said. "This is tough."
“为你父亲的事我很遗憾，”我说。“这很难过。”
She stared at me, and I held the gaze. "I mean it. I'm sorry."
她盯着我，我回视着。“我是认真的。我很遗憾。”
She drifted back into the house. I pulled the dolly up the stairs to Mr. Rensdales room. It'd been taken apart a little bit, the bed stripped, our gear all standing in the corner. With Mr. Rensdale gone, you could see what the room was, just a little box in the desert.
她飘回了屋里。我把手推车拉上楼梯到兰斯代尔先生的房间。它已经被稍微拆解了，床被拆空，我们的装备都在角落里。兰斯代尔先生走了，你能看出这个房间是什么，只是沙漠里的一个小盒子。
"I'm going back Friday." Elizabeth had come into the room. "I guess I'm going back to school."
“我周五回去。”伊丽莎白走进房间。“我想我该回学校了。”
"Good," I said. I didn't know what I was saying. I started to say something else, but she pointed at me.
“好的，”我说。我不知道我在说什么。我开始说别的，但她指着我。
"Don't come. Just do what you do, but don't come to the funeral. You don't have to."
“别来。做你该做的，但别来参加葬礼。你没必要来。”
"I want to," I said. Her tone had hurt, made me mad. I walked to the bed and put my hands on her shoulders.
“我想来，”我说。她的语调刺伤了我，让我生气。我走到床边，把手放在她的肩膀上。
"Don't."
“别这样。”
I bent and looked into her face.
我弯下腰看着她的脸。
"Don't."
“别这样。”
I went to pull her toward me to kiss, and she leaned away sharply. "Don't, David." But I followed her over onto the bed, and though she squirmed tight as a knot, I held her beside me, adjusting her, drawing her back against me. About a minute later, she said, "What are you doing?"
我伸手想把她拉向我亲吻，她猛地向后靠。“别这样，大卫。”但我跟着她倒在床上，虽然她挣扎得像个结，我还是把她抱在身边，调整着她，把她拉向我。大约一分钟后，她说，“你在干什么？”
"It's OK," I said.
“没事的，”我说。
Then she put her hand on my wrist, stopping it. "Don't," she said. "What are you doing?"
然后她把手放在我的手腕上，阻止了它。“别这样，”她说。“你在干什么？”
"Elizabeth," I said, kissing at her nape.
“伊丽莎白，”我说，亲吻她的后颈。
She rose to an elbow and looked at me, her face rock hard, unfamiliar. Our eyes were locked. "Is this what you came for?" She lay back and thumbed off her pants. "Is it?"
她用手肘撑起身子看着我，面容坚硬，陌生。我们的视线锁在一起。“这就是你来的目的吗？”她躺回去，推掉裤子。“是吗？”
"Yes," I said. It was the truth, and there was pleasure in saying it.
“是，”我说。这是事实，说出来有一种快感。
"Then go ahead." She moved to the edge of the bed.
“那就来吧。”她移动到床边。
She didn't move when I pulled away, just lay there looking at me. I remember it as the moment in this life when I was farthest from any of my feelings. I gathered the empty cylinder and the portable gear with the strangest thought. It's going to take me 20 years to figure out who I am now.
当我离开时她没动，只是躺在那儿看着我。我记得这是我一生中距离我任何感情最远的一刻。我带着最奇怪的想法收集了空瓶子和便携式装备。我需要20年才能弄清楚我是谁。
I could feel Elizabeth Rensdale's hatred as I would feel it dozens of times a season for many years. It's a kind of dread for me that has become a rudder and kept me out of other troubles. The next year at school, I used it to treat Linda Enright correctly, as a gentleman, and keep my distance. I had the chance to win her back, and I did not take it.
当伊丽莎白·兰斯代尔看着我时，我能感觉到她的仇恨，就像我多年来每个季节都会感觉到几十次一样。对我来说，这是一种恐惧，它已成为一种舵，让我远离了其他麻烦。第二年在学校，我用它来正确地对待琳达·恩赖特，像个绅士，保持距离。我有机会赢回她，但我没把握住。
I left for my junior year of college at Missoula three days later. The evening before my flight, my parents took me to dinner at a steakhouse on a mesa, a Western place where they cut your tie off if you wear one. My parents were proud of me, they said, working hard like this all summer away from my friends. I was changing, they said. And they could tell it was for the better.
三天后，我出发前往米苏拉读大三。我航班的前一天晚上，父母带我在台地上一家牛排馆吃晚饭，那是个西部地方，如果你系领带，他们会把它剪掉。父母说，他们为我骄傲，整个夏天远离朋友努力工作。他们说，我正在改变。他们能看出那是为了更好。
Much, much later, I drove the dark streets. The radio played a steady rotation of exactly the same songs heard today on every 50,000 watt station in this country. Every fifth song was The Supremes. I knew where I was going. Beyond the bright, rough edge of the lights of Mesa, I drove until the pavement ended. And then I dropped onto the red clay roads and found Gil Benson's house.
很久很久以后，我开过黑暗的街道。收音机里播放着今天这个国家每个5万瓦电台里听到的完全相同的歌曲。每五首歌里就有一首是至上合唱团的。我知道我要去哪儿。在梅萨明亮粗糙的灯光边缘之外，我一直开到路面结束。然后我掉进红粘土路上，找到了吉尔·本森的房子。
I knocked and called for minutes. Out back, I kicked through the debris and weeds until I found one of the back bedroom windows unlocked. And I slid it open and climbed inside. In the stale heat, I knew immediately that the house was abandoned. I called Gil's name and picked my way carefully to the hall. The lights did not work.
我敲门叫了许久。在后面，我在碎片和杂草中踢开，直到找到一扇没锁的后卧室窗户。我滑开窗户爬了进去。在陈旧的热气中，我立刻知道房子已经废弃了。我叫着吉尔的名字，小心翼翼地往走廊走。灯不亮。
I wasn't scared, but I was something else. Standing in that dark room where I had palmed old Oreos all summer long, I now had proof-- hard proof-- that I had lost Gil Benson. He hadn't made it back, and I couldn't wish him back.
我不害怕，但我是一种别的感觉。站在那个我整个夏天一直偷偷藏奥利奥的黑暗房间里，我现在有了证据——确凿的证据——我失去了吉尔·本森。他没能回来，我也没法祈求他回来。
At home, my suitcases were packed. Some big thing was closing down in me. I had spent the summer as someone else, someone I knew I didn't care for, and I would be glad when he left town. We would see each other from time to time, but I also knew he was no friend of mine. I eased along the empty roadways trying simply to gather what was left, to think. But it was like trying to fold a big blanket alone. I kept having to start over.
在家，行李箱已经打包好了。某种巨大的东西正在我体内关闭。我以另一个人度过了这个夏天，我知道我不喜欢的那个人，当他离开镇子时我会很高兴。我们不时会见到对方，但我也知道他不是我的朋友。我沿着空荡荡的公路慢慢走，试图仅仅收集剩下的东西，思考。但这就像试图独自折叠一条大毯子。我一直不得不重新开始。
The sun is going down, and three families are camped beside a trout stream in southern Utah. The women are talking to each other by the picnic table. The men are watching the children play in the water. Two of the women are sisters. One has just had an affair with a man in Los Angeles. On the phone, she swore to her sister that she would tell her husband and insist on a divorce. But now, she's thinking she will not say anything ever about the affair and maybe wait a while on the divorce.
太阳落山了，三个家庭在犹他州南部的鳟鱼溪旁露营。女人们在野餐桌旁互相交谈。男人们看着孩子们在水里玩。其中两个女人是姐妹。一个刚在洛杉矶和男人有了外遇。在电话里，她向妹妹发誓她会告诉丈夫并坚持离婚。但现在，她想她永远不会说出外遇的事，也许在离婚上等等。
Her sister is swaying back and forth with a baby in her arms. This morning, the baby stuck her right hand in a cup of hot coffee and cried for hours. Now she's asleep, but her fingers have big, balloon-like blisters that will break and heal slowly, leaving long, white scars.
她的妹妹怀里抱着婴儿前后摇晃。今天早上，婴儿把右手伸进一杯热咖啡里，哭了几个小时。现在她睡着了，但她的手指上有巨大的、气球状的水泡，它们会慢慢破裂愈合，留下长长的白色伤疤。
The third woman is two days pregnant and thinking about taking a nap. Of the men, one is trying to decide when would be the best time to drive into town and call his broker. One is thinking about running up the mountain to smoke a joint and watch the sun go down. The other is looking at the water wondering if the fish might like a grasshopper.
第三个女人怀孕两天了，正在考虑小睡一会儿。男人中，一个正试图决定什么时候去城里给经纪人打电话最好。一个正考虑跑上山抽根大麻，看着太阳落山。另一个正看着水，想鱼儿是否会喜欢蚱蜢。
The children are playing and fighting over a toy sailboat. The three-year-old boy is soaking wet and nearly out of his mind with the possibilities. The five-year-old girl is standing on the bank, making up rules and shouting out orders and dropping lettuce and cheese from her sandwich. There are little birds in the trees and big birds on the rock walls of the canyon-- red rock walls in the shadow of the afternoon sun.
孩子们正在玩耍，为一个玩具帆船打架。三岁的男孩浑身湿透，几乎被可能性冲昏了头脑。五岁的女孩站在岸边，编造规则，大声发号施令，从三明治上掉下生菜和奶酪。树上有小鸟，峡谷的岩壁上有大鸟——下午阳光阴影下的红岩墙。
A dirt road comes around and down and crosses over the stream, and in the pool below the road, a pale snake slides silently into the water and swims to the other side, holding something rather large in its mouth. There are three cars, all white, and there's an Indian-- or rather, the ghost of an Indian who lived and died in this spot-- sitting cross-legged on the hood of the station wagon.
一条土路绕过来往下，穿过小溪，在路下方的水潭里，一条苍白的蛇静静地滑入水中，游向另一边，嘴里衔着什么相当大的东西。有三辆车，全是白色的，有一个印第安人——或者更确切地说，一个曾在这个地方生活并死去的印第安人的幽灵——盘腿坐在旅行车的引擎盖上。
This is the beginning of a story. The story is about how the husband realizes his wife has been unfaithful. And it's about how the Indian died and what the snake had in its mouth and how the two-day-old life inside the mother grows and is born and becomes a beautiful young woman who paints the poems of Rilke on the desert blacktop highway. The sun is going down, and three families are camped beside a trout stream in southern Utah. This is the beginning of a story, but there isn't enough time to tell it.
这是一个故事的开头。这个故事关于丈夫如何意识到妻子出轨了。它关于印第安人是如何死的，蛇嘴里衔着什么，母亲体内的两天大的生命如何成长，出生并成为一位美丽的年轻女子，她在沙漠黑色柏油公路上写下里尔克的诗。太阳落山了，三个家庭在犹他州南部的鳟鱼溪旁露营。这是故事的开头，但没有足够的时间讲述它。
Scott Carrier, and Ron Carlson before him.
斯科特·卡里尔，在他之前的罗恩·卡尔森。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。